he's a president who likes meeting
people
only yesterday he welcomed portugal's
leader antonio costa to the elysee
both men are now self-isolating after
emmanuel macron
tested positive for covert on monday the
spanish prime minister
and european council president shah
michelle were in paris
two days before president macron began
to feel unwell
masks were worn but social distancing
sometimes forgotten
french officials say president macron
will stay in isolation for seven days
but is still running the country and
will hold meetings remotely
his positive test leading many in paris
to question who else could be infected
he's like everybody he faces the same
threat as his fellow countrymen
and i hope the problem is he won't be
the only one to have to deal with this
considering the number of people he's in
contact with throughout the day
we can all get infected without
realizing it even if you follow sanitary
measures
it shows how serious this is anyone can
get it
[Music]
just days ago president macron met
almost all eu leaders in brussels for a
summit
his tactile nature often on display and
now french officials say he was very
lightly infected at the time
leading to concern about other leaders
macron's positive test comes at a
critical moment for the brexit talks
here in the belgian capital the eu 27
will need to sign off on any deal if he
were to become
incapacitated which seems highly
unlikely he's a young guy
and he does have symptoms but he's said
to be working normally but if that were
to happen
you have a french line of command
and i'm sure that decisions would be
delegated to the next level um so
i really don't see this as a crucial
obstacle
proving the point his officials had been
making that he was still an active
president
emmanuel macron addressed foreign
ministry officials via video link
late in the day covid and isolation
haven't stopped him working michelle
clifford sky news
brussels